[Music]
appsheet empowers your company to build
apps that are flexible and scalable
without engineering resources
its clever no code platform is easy for
any employee to use while providing
visibility
and security to your rit department
consider an example where a team in your
organization needs a new tool
your rit department likely doesn't have
the time or resources to evaluate new
solutions for a single team
fortunately appsheet combines
administrative tools such as setting
controls on data access
with day-to-day products like google
sheets this means the urit department
can set organization-wide limits which
employees can work within
while customizing their own solutions
let's take a look at how a facility
management team was able to build their
own inventory system
here the team uses pen and paper to
inventory equipment throughout multiple
buildings
later adding their updates to a google
sheet
the process is slow and often inaccurate
some buildings need new or additional
pieces of equipment while others may
have extra items unaccounted for
it has a received request to improve the
way these items are tracked by
developing a custom application
but that effort is sitting in a backlog
behind other projects with higher
priority
the team most familiar with the
inventory process is the facility
management team
and they've decided to take on this
project themselves by using app sheet
the no code development platform the
current process requires many users
contributing to a single google sheet
this sheet contains all of the assets
and their locations across multiple
buildings
to upgrade this sheet into an
application the team lead starts by
connecting the shared google sheet
to appsheet the spreadsheet will serve
as the source of data for the new
application
behind the scenes appsheet is
automatically detecting the types of
data connected
establishing relationships between data
sources and building an app interface
that's easy to use
with a few clicks the tables of
buildings and items have been connected
and appsheet has generated a functional
prototype
this prototype already contains a map of
the buildings
methods for adding items and updating
the status of each one
as well as intuitive ways to see lists
of items organized by the building in
which they're located
at this point the app creator can easily
install this application on their mobile
device
where any future updates made to the app
will be instantly reflected
and any time the app is used updates are
synced back to the database for the
application
in this case the connected google sheet
the team lead can customize their new
tool by adding additional features to
their app
for example with a few clicks the team
adds a dashboard displaying the
real-time status of every piece of
equipment
now everyone who was carrying a
clipboard around the facilities can
check the dashboard from the mobile app
or their computer
to create this dashboard the team lead
adds a view
selects dashboard and then chooses what
data to include
the team also adds barcode scanning to
help users quickly and accurately
identify different pieces of equipment
to enable barcode and nfc tag scanning
the team lead simply flips a toggle
option
on a field-by-field basis depending on
the data that's been connected
lastly email workflows can be created to
automatically notify team members when
inventory gets low
or if there are unused items that could
be moved to another building
this email workflow is enabled by
creating a new workflow
specifying the type of notification and
customizing an email template that will
be filled out with the appropriate
information
based on app content this app is ready
to start using right away
and it can be shared with individuals or
teams similar to how google doc is
shared
and it can be updated as needed based on
future feedback
the team was able to build their own
solution relieving id of this backlogged
project while still maintaining control
of what's created and how data is
accessed
for example establishing a policy so
that app creators can share their apps
only with other employees in their group
other policies can control things like
how data is accessed or what features
can be included in apps
appsheets no code development
environment is what enables solutions
like this
other teams in this organization can
take advantage of the platform in
similar ways to help manage projects
coordinate field staff or automate
internal operations
empowering a single team to improve
their daily work while
ensuring the entire organization
operates with clear boundaries is
exactly the sort of flexible and
collaborative solution that appsheet was
designed for